it's the first day of daylight savings
yeah yes this weekend as you know this
weekend we this weekend we all move to
our clocks ahead by one hour yes in
other words that's our show good night
everybody
why are you happy it's over first you
sit down right away
and then at the mere suggestion it's
over before it even began you're dancing
in the aisle
well time to eat let's go let's get out
of here what else is going on this
interesting White House adviser Kelly on
Conway suggested that President Obama
could have spied on Donald Trump through
a microwave oven through a microwave
oven yeah which is why today the Trump
administration brought in six hot
pockets for questioning like all right
you mugs what do you guys know
good night everybody
they're still enjoyed I was gonna
president Trump says he's planning to
travel less to other countries than
previous presidents yeah yes the idea
was first suggested to him by other
countries like maybe
when I get a laugh I eat it like a
peanut um uh what else is going on this
week president Trump will meet with a
Saudi prince that's right yes the man
born into immense wealth with multiple
wives and an exotic head covering says
he can't wait to meet the Saudi prince
you really have to be paying attention
to like that joke yeah oh now I want to
stress everyone's okay everyone's okay
but over the weekend off the coast of
Florida a Carnival cruise ship almost
hit two jet skiers yeah
today the captain of the ship apologized
and said I'll get them next time
most people come on
I hate those [ __ ] don't you I think
that's what I'm simulating yeah anyone
watching without the sound on doesn't
know you're doing right now study just
came out of study reveals 40% of women
have trouble achieving orgasm 40% I'm no
scientist but based on my research that
percentage is a lot higher I can tell
you I've been around I'm thinking 90%
maybe then I got to mention this true
story this is a real thing
yesterday was Japan's annual penis
festival penis festival in Japan Israel
also had its penis festival but they had
to cut it short
because it's circumcision I'd like to
explain it when it's not necessary
you